on va tout de suite passer à info intox
[Musique]
Anthony Saint-Léger bonsoir bonsoir
Audrey bonsoir à tous ça y est le
Mondial au Qatar a commencé une coupe du
monde on le sait synonyme de polémique
on en a parlé c'est l'occasion aussi de
véhiculer des fantasmes et des rumeurs
effectivement et dès le premier jour des
hier donc le premier jour de la
compétition des publications en français
en anglais ou en encore en arabe ont
affirmé que des personnes étaient venues
expressément au Qatar pendant la coupe
du monde pour se convertir à l'islam
elles étaient leurs propos au moyen de
cette vidéo où l'on voit quatre hommes
et on entend surtout quatre hommes
récités ces paroles j'atteste qu'il n'y
a pas de divinité excepté à là et
j'atteste que Mahomet est le messager
d'Allah on voit ici deux personnes et
notamment cette personne ici qui va nous
intéresser plus tard je vous expliquerai
pourquoi alors cette phrase qui a été
prononcée correspond en fait à celle que
doit prononcer quiconque qui souhaite
embrasser finalement la foi musulmane et
plusieurs comptes qu'il a partagé et
bien cette scène a eu lieu au Qatar donc
pendant la Coupe du Monde et l'homme que
j'ai entouré sur la vidéo serait Zakir
naïque c'est à dire un prédicateur
indien controversé sur lequel on va
revenir un petit peu plus tard pour ce
qui est de sa personnalité alors ces
images elles sont authentiques mais
elles n'ont rien à voir avec la Coupe du
Monde effectivement et pourquoi lorsque
l'on recherche ces mots sur Google
Qatar Islam Zakir naïque est plus
précisément sur l'onglet vidéo de Google
en le restreignant à cette date donc
avant le 31 octobre
2022 et bien on retrouve une vidéo
publiée vous le voyez en mai 2016 dans
laquelle on retrouve en fait
l'événement en question on retrouve le
même décor et le même intervenant en
l'occurrence ici le titre de la vie de
la vidéo est-ce que Dieu existe pas
existe pardon par asakir Nike adoa au
Qatar est toujours vous le voyez de 2016
donc cette même conférence elle est
documentée dans une autre vidéo que l'on
voit ici qui date elle aussi de 2016 et
dans cette vidéo on va retrouver la
séquence partagée tout à l'heure avec
les deux hommes en question donc l'homme
présenté comme étant Zakir naïque et les
quatre personnes récitant les mêmes
paroles puisque dans cette vidéo il y a
les mêmes paroles que tout à l'heure en
recherchant davantage et en tapant par
exemple sur Facebook le nom de la
conférence et le nom de Zakir naïque on
retombe sur cette publication de mai
2016 ou le prédicateur en question fait
la publicité de cette événement un
cathartour dit-il comme d'ailleurs
promotion que l'on retrouve sur le média
catary pro gouvernemental Halles Shark
dans cet article toujours du 28 mai 2016
en l'occurrence et qui est ce Zakir un
naïque et bien Zakir naïque c'est lui
cet homme que l'on voit sur la photo un
indien médecin de formation qui a créé
la Fondation pour la Recherche islamique
il a créé aussi fondé peace TV une
chaîne de télévision qui a environ 200
millions de téléspectateurs et qui est
interdite en Inde au Pakistan au
Royaume-Uni ou encore au Canada parce
que contrairement à ce que pourrait
laisser penser son nom et le véhicule
des contenus incitant au terrorisme et à
la haine Zakir et Nike qui est
d'ailleurs poursuivi en Inde pour
incitation à la haine et accessoirement
aussi pour blanchiment d'argent il est
actuellement exilé en Malaisie un
prédicateur controversé donc qui a
affiché il y a quelques années
publiquement son soutien Oussama à Ben
Laden le fondateur d'Al-Qaïda Zakir
naïque qui est pour leur bien présent au
Qatar pour des conférences religieuses
mais vous l'aurez compris la vidéo
partagée tout à l'heure ne montre pas
l'une de ces conférences donc
contrairement à ce qu'on voulut montrer
certaines publications qui survent
surtout ce lot de de polémique et de
critique liée donc aussi à la très
stricte application de la religion liée
à donc à l'émirats conservateurs merci
beaucoup Anthony Saint Léger on s'arrête
là pour info un toc nous on se retrouve
dans quelques minutes pour un nouveau
journal vous restez avec nous sur France
[Musique]